Il n'y aurait pas de nécessité
de réformer le système de retraites
s'il n'y avait pas
une problématique de démographie.
Là où, dans les années 70,
il y avait 4 actifs par retraité,
il y en a aujourd'hui 1,7.
Il y en aura dans quelques années plus que
1,5 donc, ce qui crée mécaniquement
un problème de déséquilibres financiers
et budgétaires du système de retraites.
C'est la raison pour laquelle la réforme
apparaît nécessaire.
Ce que nous voulons
proposer, c'est un contrat social,
c'est un contrat sociétal avec les entreprises,
avec les partenaires sociaux,
de façon à ce qu'on puisse résoudre
ce problème de taux d'emploi des seniors
qui va participer aussi à l'équilibre
financier des régimes de retraite.
Le taux d'emploi des seniors en France
est inférieur à la moyenne européenne,
il est de 16 points
inférieur au taux en Allemagne.
Clairement, c'est totalement
insatisfaisant et c'est la raison pour
laquelle le groupe MoDem à l'Assemblée nationale
propose un système de modulation
des cotisations des entreprises
en fonction du taux des seniors.
Ni plus ni moins qu'un bonus-malus, sur
le même principe que les contrats courts.
C'est un système qui fonctionne parfaitement.
La réforme des retraites
va permettre d'avancer sur la question de
la pénibilité du travail, sur la question
du taux d'emploi des seniors,
sur une meilleure prise
en compte de la pénibilité
et puis une prise en
compte également des carrières hachées
qui touchent notamment les femmes.
Une autre de nos propositions,
c'est une meilleure prise en compte
de la maternité des femmes.
Lorsque les femmes ont eu des enfants,
elles se heurtent souvent
à un problème de carrières hachées,
qui, arrivées au moment des retraites,
les pénalisent très fortement
dans le niveau des pensions.
Donc, nous proposons des trimestres
supplémentaires pour les femmes.
Clairement, les débats parlementaires
ne sont pas au niveau de l'importance
de la réforme.
L'obstruction recherchée
par la NUPES, par LFI
est absolument scandaleuse.
Elle nuit au débat parlementaire.
Elle va nous empêcher de traiter
d'un certain nombre de sujets.
Elle va, par exemple,
nous empêcher de traiter de la pénibilité.
C'est la raison pour laquelle nous leur
demandons de retirer un certain nombre
de leurs amendements, de façon à pouvoir
aborder ces sujets dans l'hémicycle.
Le débat, c'est dans l'hémicycle,
ce n'est pas dans la rue.